everybody's Gary Vaynerchuk from Wine
Library TV and garyvaynerchuk.com that's
where we are right now
and I really wanted to address this
revision3 thing I feel like too many
people have asked me about it so I
address it but I'm gonna dress it more
global as you could tell by the title of
this video why don't we wait for hard
times to make smart decisions right and
so everybody so go the economic meltdown
and Oh Gary you're so bullcrap you're
saying things are good I am saying
things are good I'm gonna tell you why
for some reason it takes you know the
news of crisis or things of that nature
to meet people rethink stuff you know
sometimes people have a death in the
family or near death experience and they
relive their life slot you know they go
a different direction or just more
simple not as a skeptic and large when
you're running a business when they
kinda gets a little topper you start
making better decisions you start
looking
and so what revision3 did in my opinion
was just made some really smart
decisions I mean let's I don't really
know much about their epic food deal but
let me definitely tell you about the
shows that they canceled and what they
did with me obviously the shows they
canceled just weren't getting viewership
it was tough for them to monetize I mean
you know that's what networks do all the
time I mean obviously Martin Sargent and
Sarah these guys are amazingly amazing
you know internet superstars with a lot
of track record and equity and so it
makes big news but at the end of day
dinner did superstar pop star and
weren't doing well they needed to cancel
it cuz they were spending funds and
money and effort and time on building
something that they weren't able to
monetize against something you should
think about with your blog anyway it's
like it's 10 o'clock do you know anyway
um and with my deal you know why not my
team Ian was a distribution deal with
revision3 I mean what they had at the
end of the day was the right to turn an
episode of wine lobby TV into a smaller
episode of Wine Library Reserve where
Glenn would edit it down but that was a
lot of work because you gotta take a
crap load of me and you know the you
know and then shrink it down to five
minutes and you know that's just a lot
of work and tougher to monetize because
so much 90 something percent of my
traffic comes to wine webby tv.com or
actually iTunes as a mine look at the
iTunes link if you want to watch my
Larry TV on iTunes we'll link that up
for you right now
so you know they weren't getting the
mass of the traffic so it's hard for
them to monetize it it wasn't their own
property at the other day I would have
kicked my sorry ass off there too heck
if I was in the reverse
it would have never happened in the
first place you need to control your own
game right I mean at the end of the day
you know they need to make smarter and
bigger and better business decisions and
if the economy which I'm not so sold
that that's the rationale made them you
know shed their fat and focus on
entities they own and can get ROI
against that makes a hell of a lot of
sense to me mod I mean there's no reason
that they should not be able to monetize
against me and spend all that time and
effort so made a lot of sense I totally
get where they're coming from
I give them kudos obviously for me on my
end I've been plumbing y'all nothing
changed before after I think Mott here
is a little happy cuz he's got one less
thing to do a day obviously I have a lot
of fun being a part of that platform
it's a great platform and I wish those
guys well and it helped me pick up new
fans and that's probably the downside
but it's really no different than me
stopping to upload from YouTube I mean
while I be TV com has always been the
home and the traffic but at the end of
the day with the real question on
revision3 and everybody else is why do
people wait for the tough times this is
what I such great businesses are built
during these times this is why I keep
telling you to go out and hustle build
something right now because gonna be
making really shrewd and sharp business
decisions with real ways to monetize
because there's not stupid money being
flowed around or stupid theories or
stupid decisions people are tightened up
which means that it's gonna be tighter
stronger and better from a business
model so kudos to revision3 and i hope
other people are gonna start making
really smart decisions because that's
how you win and you know that's it make
smart decisions whether the economy is
good or bad